it's a breaking news to bring you on Sky
News Today concerns Nikki Haley an
American politician her name will be
very familiar to many of you and this is
her announcing her bid for the white
house so let's just do this on Twitter
in the past few minutes I'm running she
says for president who is Nikki Haley
well she's an American Diplomat and
politician who was the first female
governor of South Carolina that role she
occupied from 2011 to 2017. many will
know her when she was appointed by
President Trump as the 29th U.S
ambassador to the United Nations that
was a role she had when Mr Trump took
office from January 2017 through to
December
2018. so very familiar to many it was
widely expected that she might enter the
race and Confirmation in the past few
minutes there she is confirming indeed
that she will enter the race for the
White House so of course I wonder what
president Trump will make of that he
appointed her as U.S ambassador to the
United Nations he is standing himself so
uh we will get reaction to that as it
develops so that's Nikki Haley though
um who has announced her candidacy to
become the next president of the United
States